[Música]
como se trata de evolución yo creo que
la palabra evolución sugiere que ha
habido un cambio o que se está cambiando
o que bueno que vamos hacia algo bueno
que estamos moviéndonos para algo
pero sin embargo en lo que se refiere al
objetivo de conseguir la igualdad de
oportunidades entre hombres y mujeres
sobre todo en el mundo en el que yo me
muevo que es el mundo de la empresa
llevo más de 30 años recorriendo países
parís-nueva york y españa para terminar
muy felizmente
yo veo que en el mundo de la empresa el
conseguir la igualdad de oportunidades
algo que va demasiado lento yo apenas lo
estoy sintiendo y estoy de una empresa
que es un referente de esas empresas que
dicen que practican la igualdad
bueno entonces
es este fase yo quiero evocar lo
encontré con tres anécdotas tres
situaciones de los últimos meses
la primera el primer caso un poco bueno
vivido todos son casos reales me invitan
en parís no puedo decir en qué escuela
superior de negocios no escuela superior
de negocio
para con otro ponente un señor vamos a
ir más lejos de arica era francés hay
mucho federico hans beck a perder y que
vamos a quemarlo frederic bueno
friederike y yo nos invitan a esta
escuela alta escuela de negocio para que
aconsejamos a mujeres que han terminado
una titulación importantísima en estos
vuelos ha terminado por supuesto la ley
sanz como dice los franceses la matriz
alguna tienen un máster y algunas han
venido a esa ponencia que yo iba a dar y
quería y a la ponencia del feder y este
señor
para que le aconseje bueno la directora
del colegio de lector superación de
ecommerce me dice maría luisa bueno es
para que aconseje ellos a estas mujeres
que han terminado pues la verdad es que
es muy difícil no puedo decir nombre de
la escuela pero cuando sales de ahí
sales preparadas son mujeres
preparadísima para que bueno tú que eres
consejera de varios consejos de una
multinacional y fue de aquí que es una
especialista de derecho de sociedades
que además están varios consejos con un
hombre una mujer bueno que aconseje a
éstas
a estas personas a esta licenciada si
tal
bueno pues el g de ají que eran unas 250
personas la sala está en parís
general que era el único hombre de la
sala y me dijo no te importa como soy el
único hombre que yo hablé antes que tú
te lo nombre que es el caballero en la
vida
tienes la palabra fe derecha y el café
de bacon
pues tomó la palabra y me lo agradeció
porque era un hombre educado y la
directora también me dijo estupendo que
hable francesa y que más técnico y tú
que eres más
más humanistas pues muy bien empezó al
feder hay que hablar bueno para ir
rápido porque esto el control lo tengo
aquí el frederick que el señor fred el
que dijo se dirigió a las mujeres y le
dijo por favor yo tengo entre otras
cosas un consejo muy importante que
daros y sobre todo es que sepáis que si
como hay una ley de representación
equilibrada en francia los consejos de
administración que ha entrado en vídeo
recientemente muchas de vosotras vais a
entrar en un consejo de administración
pero por favor una cosa os pido cuando
lleguéis a ese consejo de administración
a ese comité de dirección si no se
encontraría la altura de la situación
porque son buenos son temas técnicos
financieros económicos estratégicos y
bueno hasta ahí los primeros que tienen
que hacer es iros
rápidamente es mejor decir que bueno
pues que las razones que quieran evocar
pero os vais porque vais a hacer si no
vais hacer un desprestigio para las
otras mujeres y eso no se hace claro
claro frederic te dijo eso
pues toda la escuchada frente a rito
terminó el tema
y claro tome la palabra yo sé que tengo
muchas cosas más todas ellas un poco con
esta filosofía tan alegre y tan emotiva
me tocó la palabra amigo dije pues
muchísimas gracias federico y a mis
compañeras del súper géneros de comer se
les dije que la primera cosa que yo les
aconsejaba es que nos siguieran en
absoluto lo que frente a que toda va
desde script
que afortunadamente me teniendo yo la
suerte de hablar después de derecho y
que federico en lugar de animarla a
asumir ese reto porque estamos súper
preparadas y ella están todavía más
preparada que yo porque es una
generación que se ocupa o sea que están
haciendo que tienen esta preocupación
por llegar bueno y yo le pregunté a
frederica y os pregunta ustedes ustedes
pensáis que hay muchísimos hombres que
cuando llegan a los consejos de
administración y no se sienten a la
altura hacia alguno no se siente a la
altura que ya sería extrañísimo que no
se sintieran pero sí por con salidas se
sienten y fallan
vosotros creéis que ustedes creéis que
ellos se van ahí sobre todo para no
desprestigiar al gremio de los hombres
bueno según la experiencia hace un mes
me invitan una red de mujeres sería
interesante
bueno para que yo hablo en una mesa
redonda y me dice maría luisa van a
haber muchos hombres
porque claro y dando a ver sobre todo
muchos hombres que practiquen la
igualdad en sus empresas y van a ver
mesas redondas y aquí vienen los hombres
a dar la cara digo cómo dar la cara y sí
sí a decir que son feministas y que
tienen y que están defendiendo todos los
días a menos que son feministas que han
comprendido y que van a acompañarnos en
este movimiento feminista pues yo me lo
pude perder y les dije a mi consejero
delegado de renault oye que tú tienes
que venir y lo puse en la mesa alguna de
las mesas hubo varias bueno
rápidamente yo con la moderadora y me
voy a la mesa a la mesa de los cinco
ponentes que eran empresarios
seleccionados porque eran gente
aunque practicaban la wada y la
moderadora que era una persona
inteligente es una amiga es una
compañera
le hizo la pregunta claro si venían a
dar la cara la primera pregunta era tu
eres feminista
claro tú eres feminista porque no yo no
soy feminista dijo el primero
sitio está la segundo no nos que nos
hemos comprendido muy bien yo tampoco
soy feminista el tercero
hay que yo creía que lo de ser feminista
era una pregunta que se hacía contra él
y bueno la definición de la real
academia española en materia de la
definición del feminismo cuál se repite
mela
repito es simplemente la defensa de la
igualdad de derechos de hombres y
mujeres bueno pues si es así
efectivamente eso no plantea muchos
problemas de principio pero bueno no
estoy seguro
5 luego 1
si muchos de nosotros conocemos nos
alegraríamos si yo pudiese decir su
nombre y yo soy feminista
sorprendente no parece los hombres
seleccionados de las empresas que
practican la igualdad último caso hace
una semana
una ong internacional que hace un
trabajo extraordinario en materia social
y humanitaria en muchísimos países del
mundo me llamo maría luisa te
necesitamos vale para qué
para un grupo de reflexión que hemos
creado en esta ong
en realidad un grupo de sabios dijo pero
sí muy sabios
expertos del mundo de la empresa
presidentes al cual y es para
reflexionar sobre las desigualdades que
engendra la globalización lo sabemos
todo hay muchísimas desigualdades y este
grupo de expertos que nosotros esta
organización importante no puede nombrar
la hemos hemos nombrado y pues
rapidísimamente
bueno y queremos que todo esté en ese
grupo de efectos muy rápidas rápidas
porque veo esto llegó al grupo de
expertos era una comida y estaban aquí
los sabios sorpresa eran nueve sabios
allí no había ninguna savia se suponía
que sería yo se equivocaron también
inútil decir bueno inútil fue increíble
la sorpresa porque el hombre es tan
sabio que además algunos de vosotros
conocéis a varios que son personas
inteligentes preparadas como podrían
ponerse a reflexionar sobre las
desigualdades en el mundo
sin pensar que uno de los aspectos de la
desigualdad en el mundo es la
desigualdad en materia de género
y como no se podían reunir los nueve
hombres para reflexionar sobre la
desigualdad es sin pensar que una de las
sabias entre comillas que era yo pues
era una de las personas víctimas de esas
desigualdades en la empresa o sea pero
hombre tenemos que invitar a más mujeres
y ya voy terminando tenemos que invitar
a más mujeres
empezaron a reírse y algunos dijeron
pues nosotros no somos como tú nosotros
hubiésemos participado en un grupo de
reflexión incluso si hubiese habido más
mujeres que hombres
digo yo también invita messi es el caso
vale
esos hombres me hicieron de france de
opinar de manera irónica que yo no tenía
razón pero tengo que ser honesta hubo
uno que me escribió una carta unos días
después
diciéndome que bueno que lo opinaba que
lo que yo pretendía esto y lo que él yo
es decir hacer un grupo de reflexión
sobre las desigualdades en el mundo en
un eje tan importante podría ser al
menos respetar una cierta paridad para
terminar conclusión una idea
el combate la lucha feminista es un
combate de mujeres las mujeres tenemos
que estar unidas cualquiera que sea
nuestra ideología esto no es una
cuestión de ideología el movimiento
feminista es un movimiento ya lo dijeron
muchos y no puedo decir el nombre y lo
están demostrando actualmente en españa
es un movimiento en marcha
tenemos que estar solo las mujeres
podemos dar ese cambio social que el
feminismo está planteando solo las
mujeres entre las mujeres cualquiera que
sea la ideología que tengamos y los
hombres que quieran acompañarnos que
vengan para acelerar el movimiento pero
el movimiento es nuestro y el cambio
solo podemos producirlo
nosotras muchas gracias
[Aplausos]